tras su visita a colombia del 8 al 10 de
junio la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos emitió sus
observaciones tras más de dos meses de
paro nacional conclusiones que no dejan
bien parado al gobierno de iván duque la
comisión constató que de manera
reiterada en diversas regiones del país
la respuesta del estado se caracterizó
por el uso excesivo desproporcionado de
la fuerza en muchos casos la actuación
incluyó la fuerza letal ante este
panorama la cdh entregó 41
recomendaciones al estado la principal
separar a la policía y a su escuadrón
móvil antidisturbios esmad del
ministerio de defensa también el
organismo recomendó que los bloqueos los
cuales la ley de h llama cortes de ruta
no pueden ser prohibidos de manera
generalizada una afirmación que va en
contra del discurso del estado
colombiano quien afirma que los bloqueos
son un delito
nadie puede recomendarle a un país ser
tolerante con actos de criminalidad pero
los actos de vandalismo los actos de
terrorismo urbano de baja intensidad los
bloqueos que atentan contra los derechos
de los ciudadanos están siendo
enfrentados con la constitución y la ley
las ideas jan hintze finalmente la
instalación de un mecanismo especial de
seguimiento en materia de derechos
humanos para colombia' algo a lo que la
vicepresidenta marta lucía ramírez se
opuso al considerarlo innecesario pues
calificó de sólida la institucionalidad
colombiana
la comisión condenó por otra parte la
infiltración de grupos vandálicos que
ocasionaron grandes pérdidas económicas
ataques e incendios a instalaciones del
estado bloqueos viales que causaron
desabastecimiento de alimentos medicinas
y combustible además de la muerte de dos
bebés ocurridas por falta de atención
médica